what do i do if i have no way of
practicing well i mean honestly when i
when i want to do something what i do is
i buy a course about how to do something
and then i follow the course and do it
so if i wanted to make a webinar then i
bought a course on making webinar and
then i followed the course to make the
webinar and so i learned the skill while
i was going through the course i would
even make the argument that you don't
even truly learn it
until you've applied it how do you know
if you read six books on sales and they
have different strategies which one is
is the right one because you've never
tested it in the battlefield i think the
biggest gains i've made have been from
investing in people who are above me to
break my beliefs about what was possible
it's going to be up to you to acquire
those skills and most of the time
acquiring those skills comes from doing
them which means you're going to suck
for a while and i think just most people
aren't willing to try because they think
that if they are perfect
they'll somehow not fail the first time
which is stupid because even when you're
really good you're gonna fail so
it's just people like procrastinating
and reading books about something that
they haven't done is a productive way of
feeling accomplished without actually
doing anything